[Music]
on this Friday night the prime
minister's closest advisor under oath
Katie telford's testimony about alleged
foreign interference when we receive
intelligence briefings of any kind we
don't leave any Stones unturned what
happens next in the investigation
fire and fury in France
the outrage over pension reforms at a
top courts decision a Fresh Approach To
Death care our huge fear of talking
about dying is killing us the new
Greener way to bury loved ones
and no contact with the outside world no
showering no problem
[Applause]
why this woman spent 500 Days in a cave
alone
global national with para Nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us tonight
she's been described as prime minister
Justin Trudeau's right hand and today
Katie Telford his top advisor appeared
in front of a parliamentary committee
looking into foreign interference in
Canadian elections and it's been a long
road to get her to speak from months of
calls from the opposition to get Telford
to testify to a liberal filibuster to
block her from appearing that's why
today some were bracing for a bombshell
back and forth but that didn't happen
I can't speak specifically to what was
discussed in briefings over the course
of those months I can't get into
unfortunately in this public setting
um what was or wasn't briefed on I can't
unfortunately go further as I've said
before I can't get into the specifics of
what you're describing I
can't speak to uh to this information
um and uh I
yeah I can't speak to that information I
think Madam chair you'll know my answer
on this which is that I can't speak to
uh thank you
Justin Trudeau's Chief of Staff
repeatedly cited National Security as to
why she couldn't offer up those details
on alleged Chinese meddling in Canada's
last two elections but in the more than
two hours of testimony Telford did offer
some insight into the line of
communication between herself and the
Prime Minister Mackenzie gray begins our
coverage tonight
from the start of her testimony Katie
talford made it clear she wouldn't be
able to say much I will do my best to
answer your questions
at the same time I must respect the law
that response became a common refrain
from the prime minister's Chief of Staff
publicly disclosing what her
intelligence agencies know or how they
come to know it can irreparably harm
Canada's national interests and put
people's lives in danger but despite
avoiding commenting on the contents of
many allegations publicly privately
Telford said no information would be
held back there is nothing that is ever
kept from the prime minister
certainly not by me much of that
intelligence shared with the Prime
Minister came from the National Security
advisor and the head of cesus documents
submitted to the committee showed
Trudeau was briefed by them six times
between October 2018 and March of this
year and often was joined by Telford but
that number excludes informal briefings
by security officials and Telfer didn't
say of true to read key documents from
their privy Council that have informed
much of global news's reporting on the
topic I can't unfortunately speak to
specifics of what the Prime Minister has
or has not been briefed on in all of
this Telford also said she couldn't
comment on new interference allegations
raised by the conservatives in a
Suburban Toronto riding ten weeks before
the 2021 election Bob saroya the then
Member of Parliament for Markham
Unionville received a cryptic and
threatening text message from beijing's
Consul General in Toronto suggesting
that he would no longer be a member of
parliament after the 2021 election and
right now it's having the NDP spent much
of their time questioning Telford on why
the Liberals haven't called a public
inquiry into the issue so I'm just
wondering
um have you ever advised through the
chair of course the Prime Minister
against launching a public inquiry and
if so why it's not clear what the
question should be it's not clear what
body is best to look at it given the
sensitive nature of the information the
choice on what body is best to further
study the alleged interference has been
given by Trudeau to David Johnston his
special rapid Tour on the issue and
pharah Mr Johnson has until May 23rd to
come to a decision
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie
[Music]
all right for more on this than analysis
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent David Aiken David when it
comes down to it Canadians want to know
if any of their elections were
compromised and what the Prime Minister
knew when he was running for office so
did we get any further in answering
those questions today
not really from today's testimony far
you know this whole issue of election
interference has become such a such a
highly charged issue that MPS really
could not get Beyond you know that
partisan back and forth the
conservatives believe the Liberals are
covering up information that would show
China work to defeat conservative
candidates the Liberals are indignant at
those suggestions and Telford herself
today reminded the committee that Canada
China relations were in fact at their
worst in decades during the last two
elections so why would China help the
Liberals now as for what the Prime
Minister knew and when he knew it
Trudeau himself has admitted he got
multiple briefings on Election
interference but neither he nor Telford
today can really provide the specifics
what exactly was he told when was he
told about what situations they say if
they did that they could be harming
National Security
okay David telford's highly anticipated
testimonies now in the book so where do
things go from here in this
investigation into alleged foreign
interference well there is there's
plenty of work still to be done what you
saw today was the work of the procedure
and house Affairs committee and they
will continue their work they're going
to hear from Witnesses next week
including from a former National
Security adviser to the PM Daniel Jean
but there's also the house Ethics
Committee they are doing their own study
and there's yet another Committee of
parliamentarians that looks at security
and intelligence issue and this
all-party group well they've got top
secret security clearance so they can
look at classified materials but they're
sworn to secrecy so they can't tell us
about it so far if we really want the
answers to the questions you asked to
the top of this segment it looks like
it's got to be a public inquiry and
that's just what all the opposition
parties been pushing for what the NDP
were talking about and as Mackenzie
reminded us David Johnson's mission is
to advise the PM whether or not to hold
that inquiry and Trudeau has said he's
going to do whatever Johnson recommends
now privately liberal MPS are telling me
they don't see how Johnson can avoid
recommending that an independent
Inquirer ought to be held now the trick
after that would be finding that
perfectly neutral King solomon-like
figure to preside over such a commission
and perhaps even trickier what sort of
terms of reference would that inquiry
have that would satisfy all parties
tricky pharah and who makes those terms
of reference David Aiken in Ottawa thank
you
former Ontario Progressive conservative
MPP Vincent who is now sitting as an
independent says he served global news
with a notice of libel in relation to
allegations of election interference by
China on March 10th Global News reported
that according to intelligence sources
cuss served as a financial intermediary
in Chinese Communist Party interference
schemes denies the allegations and
resigned from the Ontario Progressive
conservative caucus shortly after the
report the Ford government acknowledged
it had been briefed by ceases and
Premier Doug Ford says cut will be
allowed back into caucus if he is
cleared
to Europe now key parts of friends is
unpopular plan to raise the retirement
age has been approved stoking Rage
that's simmered for months anger boiled
over in Paris as demonstrators hit the
streets in response the Constitutional
Council approved changing the retirement
age from 62 to 64. president Emmanuel
macron says the population's aging and
the change is needed to keep the pension
system afloat but as Crystal commencing
Reports it's triggered the country's
worst social unrest in years
what's up even before nightfall Riot
police and the French Capital scrambled
to multiple locations trying to get a
handle on demonstrations the French
prime minister said there are no winners
or losers after pension reforms were
determined to be legal but there is
anger what can I say I'm shocked we're
living in a democracy and it's not a
democracy
climate of anger is what one group
signed read outside Paris City Hall
others chanted macro get out
it's disgusting says this pensioner this
will perpetuate the violence yeah
making good on an election pledge
Emmanuel macron is pushing back the age
for people to collect their full
pensions from 62 to 64. the changes will
be phased in starting in 2027 but the
process to implement the reforms will
get underway September 1st
the changes prompted weeks of national
strikes and protests some of which
turned violent and destructive on March
16th the government used What opposition
and trade unions call the nuclear option
in the French Constitution to push
through the legislation article 49.3
allows the government to bypass a vote
by MPS
the head of the general Confederation of
labor unions says workers are united and
are being called on to keep up the
pressure with another massive
demonstration planned for May 1st
Crystal commands in Global News London
the leaders of Brazil and China have
pledged to bolster cooperation between
the two Nations as the pair met for
widely anticipated talks in the Chinese
Capital today Xi Jinping welcomed Louise
Lula de Silva with full military honors
at the Great Hall of the people talks
between the leaders are said to have
largely focused on trade ties with the
pair overseeing the signing of
agreements in 15 areas ranging from
agriculture to Aeronautics the meetings
underscored the improved relations
between the two Nations since Lula took
over from his predecessor jair bolsonaro
in January
a major prisoner swap is underway in
Yemen a glimmer of hope and a
devastating eight-year conflict
up to 900 detainees could be exchanged
over the next three days under the U.N
broker deal but it's believed thousands
are still being held in a conflict
that's evolved from a civil war to a
proxy war between saudi-backed
government forces and iranian-backed
houthi Rebels the unrest has led to what
the U.N calls the world's worst
humanitarian crisis tens of thousands of
people have been killed and millions
forced to rely on food Aid to survive
the U.S Supreme Court has temporarily
lifted restrictions on a common drug
used to terminate pregnancies it means
for now that the medication will stay
widely available as a challenge moves
ahead since the fall of Roe versus Wade
last summer abortion access has been
under increasing attack in the United
States today Florida became the latest
state to enact strict new limits on
access to abortion but as Jackson prosco
reports Republican lawmakers are still
pushing for a nationwide ban
late at night and with little Fanfare
Florida's governor signed the
restrictive new abortion bill into law
70 years 40 days Mr Speaker after state
legislators approved a ban on virtually
all abortions after six weeks before
many know they're pregnant we stand for
life we stand with mothers it's a
stunning move by a state with the
highest abortion rate in the U.S demand
for pregnancy terminations in Florida
has soared by 60 percent
since neighboring states have severely
restricted access following the Supreme
Court's decision to overturn Federal
protections essentially this is kind of
yet one more door closing on access to
abortion in the American South yet
Republican lawmakers keep trying to go
further they're pushing for a National
Abortion ban Idaho recently made it a
felony to assist a minor in obtaining an
out-of-state abortion Texas is
attempting to block websites that offer
information about Reproductive Rights
while a Texas judge revoked regulatory
approval for methopristone the most
commonly used drug in medical abortions
people that are going to be most
impacted by not having access to these
safe and legal pills are people who are
low income they are most likely rural
usually people of color Friday the
Supreme Court temporarily halted the
Texas ruling the court could make a
formal ruling on access to methopristone
as early as next week we are going to
continue to fight in the courts we
believe that the the law is on our side
and we will prevail
it's clear abortion will be a defining
issue in the 2024 election a majority of
Americans support legal access I think
the more the stakes are raised and the
more the prospect of a nationwide
criminal ban is on the table the harder
that's going to be for American voters
that likely won't stop the race toward
more restrictive measures as Republicans
shift further to the extremes putting
Reproductive Rights on the line
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
in South Florida's Flood Zone Fort
Lauderdale is still under a state of
emergency tonight after Wednesday's
record rainfall the storm dropped more
than two feet of rain over parts of the
state in just seven hours turning roads
and runways into rivers and it
completely shut down the city's
International Airport which finally
reopened today there is a chance of even
more rain tonight
a pork processing plant in Quebec is
shutting down coming up the consequences
for one small community
to go back now where the closing of a
slaughterhouse south of Quebec City is
set to cost the region close to a
thousand jobs meet producer olimel
announced it will shutter its pork plant
in the town of Valley jeongxion by the
end of the year a move it calls
inevitable due to a labor shortage
inflation and changing markets Mike
Armstrong looks into the latest casualty
of this country's evolving economy
the company says it doesn't have much of
a choice the factory is one of four
alimel uses to slaughter and process
Hogs mostly for export that's gotten
tougher the Chinese market now produces
for itself and there's increased
International competition we know it's a
tough decision alimo's President says
the company processes about a hundred
and five thousand pigs a week in four
plants and by the end of the year wants
to cut that by about 20 percent we don't
need four plants to do that we only need
trees so that pretty much sums it up
closing the plant means laying off 984
people it'll be a major blow not only to
the town but to the
regional's population is only about 2
000 the plant draws from a wide area the
mayor says each of the alimel jobs means
three spin-off jobs it's hard to replace
these jobs since a food researcher and
professor at Dalhousie University the
closure he says will hurt but he says
early Mel was overextended financially
after recent takeovers and hadn't
focused on modernizing I do believe that
this is not over where actually I think
we're likely going to see another plant
close
expects Farmers Union is calling on the
province to protect the industry Farmers
they say are already suffering with
inflation now the province's biggest
agricultural export pork seeing demand
slashed
like Armstrong Global News Montreal
living under a rock literally ahead what
drove this woman to spend hundreds of
days in darkness
[Music]
Western Australia is assessing the
damage done by a category 5 storm
earlier today tropical Cyclone ilsa
slammed parts of the state with Fierce
winds and rain right before it hit the
mainland ilsa reached wind speeds
clocking 289 kilometers an hour setting
new wind records the storm's path
largely spared major population areas
there are no reports of any injuries
Elsa is expected to continue to weaken
as it moves inland
Europe's first ever mission to Jupiter
is underway
the spacecraft dubbed juice blasted off
from a rocket from French Guyana and
it's going to explore Jupiter and three
of its ice encrusted moons that are
believed to have big liquid oceans
beneath their exteriors but you're gonna
have to be patient because the
spacecraft is taking the long route and
it won't reach Jupiter until 2031.
and in Spain an extreme athlete is
finally seeing light after spending more
than a year 70 meters Underground
50 year old Beatrice lemony emerged
after 500 Days living in a cave with no
news from the outside world she missed
out on key events like the start of
Russia's war in Ukraine and Queen
Elizabeth's death with the exception of
spending eight days right outside due to
technical issues her stay was all part
of an experiment to see what the mind
and body can endure and if you're
wondering what she did there during that
time will she spent much of it to making
art exercising knitting and reading
books
yeah
next the eco-friendly alternative
replacing traditional burial methods
whether you want to acknowledge it or
not dealing with death is Big Business
one that has been mainly focused on
cremating embalming or burying in Canada
cremation is one of the most popular
options none is great for the
environment but another Greener option
is gaining traction here here's Sophie
Louis to explain Sophie
that's right and that new option is
human composting in the U.S some states
have now legalized a method that takes a
human body and turns it into soil the
first to do so was Washington State
so we went to Seattle and met Micah
Truman who feels strongly that our
approach to death care needs to change
our huge fear of talking about dying is
killing us we are unable because we
cannot face it to talk about reasonable
considered solutions that make sure that
our last act on this planet is not to
pollute it Truman is the founder of
return home a place where you can send
your loved ones to be composted or as he
likes to say Tara made it just to
explain the process to you about yay
high a couple feet high we place
Organics Alfalfa strong sawdust okay
above that we place the body yeah and
above that we place the remaining
organic so the body is essentially
cocooned inside the Organics and you
don't have to add anything else no
chemicals nothing like that nothing we
had absolutely nothing and at the end of
it you're left with this vessel full of
soil
of soil
soil that is then given to loved ones
who can use it as they like after
Claudia Mason lost her husband Rob in a
hit and run last summer she decided
terramation was the right choice for him
I knew immediately that he was going to
be composted she chose it for
environmental reasons but what she also
gained was the time to grieve human
composting is not a quick process it can
take about two months I worried very
much that when a family understood 60
days was the time that it was
unacceptable and we have never had a
single person ever have issue with 60
days ever what we give back to our
families allows them to put it in the
earth and restart the cycle of life
terramation is not available in Canada
yet but experts in What's called the
green burial movement say it is the
future of death care and that it's only
a matter of time before the option is
open to us here pharah
Sophie Louie in Vancouver thank you
Sophie to learn more about how human
composting works and other emerging
choices for green burials watch Sophie's
full report on the new reality tomorrow
night at Seven right here on global
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm foreign Asser and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your Friday evening with us tonight's
here Canada is this inukshuk in Bragg
Creek Alberta until tomorrow take care
of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]
thank you